THEORY.
>> Reporter: THESEHE EA
PUBLIC SCHOOL MA
MAGETHNT THEM BY TG RACIPREJUDI.
HER AD A SUBAC
SEINS WITH, , RACIST? ABOUT RAC
AN
PUBLICOOL TEXTBOOKS JUST THE
BATTLROD IN CTU
WABY RONAN>> OUTRAGEOUS THINGSA
ATION SA
IT PUBLISHERS CTRINATESTUDENTS.
ING CRITICAL RS E HOSON  REJECT
NC T
LEARNING IN MATH.
IT'SRT SIDE EAD ED. HT
HOTO
A LOT OF
POLITIDI BADVANTE'A Y ATSES CONA
POLITICA
MES THAT
INSIS SCHOOL ADVANCE
W YORK TIMES OE REEDBOOKS FOUNS
LI
POTIL 2024 AL CANDIDATE.
>> NOBODWA
THE TRYING TITOW
PEOPLE. THE AMERIC
YOU'RE NOT DOI TRI
ENDU IMAGD FRE PUSK
ACTHAT T
FROM, WE NEVERBACK
WORRIED IST THEM BK,THORRIED T
ANPP PROCESS FORHE